a fugitive suspected of killing a
Tennessee corrections administrator is
back behind bars this morning after a
nearly five day manhunt Kurtis ray
Watson was caught yesterday about 10
miles from West Tennessee State
Penitentiary where he escaped on a
tractor Omar Villafranca is outside the
jail in Covington where Watson is being
held Omar how has he tracked down
well good morning Anthony the Tennessee
Bureau of Investigation received 430
tips about Watson but they were finally
able to catch him after he was spotted
on someone's home security camera at
about 3:30 Sunday morning Harvey and Ann
Taylor woke up to a ring doorbell alert
showing a stranger rifling through their
refrigerator outside their front door
their surveillance camera caught Curtis
ray Watson wearing camouflage overalls a
hat and a backpack he stole from another
home the tailor is called 911 minutes
hundreds of law enforcement officers
surrounded the area conducting air and
ground searches seven hours later
Watson was spotted in a nearby soybean
field weathered and covered in ticks and
mosquito bites hands up went to his
knees and gave up immediately he was
relieved to be over with his right he
knew he wasn't getting away because of
the number of law enforcement that was
present Watson was serving a 15-year
prison sentence for especially
aggravated kidnapping that would have
expired in 2025 he is now accused of
sexually assaulting and killing 64 year
old corrections administrator Deborah
Johnson at her home on prison grounds
and he could face the death penalty
Johnson had worked in the Tennessee
Department of Corrections for 38 years
Deborah Johnson was a true corrections
professional in every way and she served
us well and the people of Tennessee well
Johnson's funeral services will be on
Friday
Watson's daughter actually issued a
statement thanking law enforcement and
offering condolences to Johnson's family
as for Watson he'll be arraigned later
on
this week and he'll have more charges
including first-degree murder
Anthony Omar thank you